[Music]
all right let's go out to
fort myers florida and talk to rebecca
hey rebecca what's going on
hey dr john how are you oh i'm just
peachy
that is the universal sign of universal
word
of kind of crappy
i've never met somebody who says i'm
doing peachy and they actually are doing
great so what's going on rebecca how's
your world
oh my world is very busy right now
but that's okay um so i am calling
because four years ago actually
four years ago the day before mother's
day i lost my mom
oh my god yeah how'd she pass away
um not of natural causes
okay yeah it was very
traumatic to our family because you know
um and so there's four of us siblings
and everything and you know
the three of us seem to deal with it
okay but my one sister
she's like really dwelling on it and i i
mean like i understand like people
grieve different but i think
she's getting obsessive she's drinking
she's like
she's just being really obsessed about
it and you know it's like i got into the
point where like i don't want to get
sucked into the drama of it
and you know it's like i'm trying to
figure out how to deal with her because
you know
me and her are the closer in age and we
grew up and we went through a lot
together
yeah and it's like i don't want to
completely shut her out but i'm at the
point of like i want to
because i don't want to get sucked into
it absolutely especially when she
probably said to me
well you don't understand you didn't
lose your mom and i'm like wait she had
me one two three four of us but okay i
don't understand
wow okay yeah so
real quick when you when you say she
didn't die of natural causes i mean did
she take her own life
no okay um i mean to be
i'm okay with it so i could be frank
because it's just when i tell people
they kind of get
really weirded out about it um have you
ever heard my show
yes i listen to you guys religiously i
would say
yeah there's not a lot of there's not a
lot of weird left so go ahead
so okay so my stepdad who who basically
raised me and
well um me and my sister that's our
stepdad and then
our brother and sister that's their dad
he has schizophrenia
and so after 20 some years he had an
episode
and he ended up stabbing my mom to death
and then calling the police saying that
he murdered his wife
okay and so yeah so no when i save
natural causes
i mean yeah yeah gotcha okay so this was
a a exclamation point trauma
right this isn't a trauma like somebody
passed away from cancers isn't
somebody took their own life this is
something that was a
violent yeah horrific evil okay
um and so you said you and the other
three
other two of you is it brothers and
sisters all sisters
yeah i have one brother and i have two
sisters okay so
one of your your brother and one of your
sisters y'all have
dealt with it okay when anyone says i've
dealt with it okay i call bull crap but
tell me what that means what does i've
dealt with it okay mean
well like okay so my brother and my
sister that's their dad
right and all that and you know i mean
we kind of like
knew okay like he was sick and stuff
but i mean like we always like knew when
an episode was gonna happen because
but he never hurt us or my mom or
anybody he always it was like try to
take his own life
so when this happened this way it was a
big shocker to all of us
so but it's like okay you know
we're just i guess we're at peace with
it but her
she is not at peace with it when you say
you're at peace with it what does that
mean
like i know i know where my mom is like
and you know i know i
one day i'll see her you know i probably
cried maybe
three times over it i did grief sharing
and i did not care for the grief sharing
because once you get to my story
everybody wants to hang on it because
you know every day you meet somebody
that's in that situation usually people
die of sicknesses
or something like that it's sensational
yeah yeah
um and i didn't want to be sensational
okay
so when you say this is four years ago
so you
you were able to tell me about it and
you you
like laughed a little bit before so
you're able to talk about it
without um your eyes welling up anymore
um you're able to have that conversation
it's not fun or pleasant it's never
something you're like hey guess what but
you're able to do that right
yeah okay um
but for uh and i know you know the
answer to this i'm just i'm gonna ask
this question for the just the average
listener
all you can four years later quote
unquote
be on a healing path right um
but you still miss your mom right oh of
course like i miss every day i mean like
before it all happened i talked to her
every day on the phone that's right you
know
because my husband's a truck driver so i
talked to him on the phone then i talked
to her on the phone
yeah you know it was like a routine i i
want people listening to know healing
doesn't mean you just don't think about
it anymore and you're all good
healing means you can breathe right you
can laugh again you can go to somebody's
birthday party again you can actually
open a christmas present again or
experience mother's day again right
um yeah without hyperventilate right
without your body taking over so
okay so when you say your sister can't
she can't
process this she can't deal with it what
does that mean she's drinking a lot what
else
um well like uh last year around fourth
of july
she because you know she's my husband
um has some issues in the past so you
know he's a recovered addict been clean
for eight years
um and all that stuff so she's like well
let me talk to him
well at the time we were all dealing
with kovid and you know he's sleeping
sick as a dog
and i'm like well he's sleeping sick and
he's like well you she goes well you
don't understand i need to talk to him
and i'm like
yeah so um then she has sent me a
picture
with a cord wrapper on her neck and she
lives in new york i live in florida
so i had to call the police department
up there and be like hey yeah
good for you good for you rebecca so
i did that and all that and then um you
know but then like
i got kind of bullied by her friends
well you're not here you're
you're not being compassionate and it's
like well i live in florida
she lives in new york i i mean i'm as
compassionate and as fair
as i possibly can you know and
you know you know i my husband and i
were talking about
he thinks because i have my kids and my
family my brother has his job and
everything my other sister has her kids
that
my sister doesn't have anything like we
do and that's probably why
she's dwelling on it so
answering one thing here her friends
don't get a vote on how you run your
life
okay they don't get to tell you the
right way to talk to your sister deal
with your sister etc that's your sister
and they may know her better than you by
now they may interact with her every day
they don't get to they don't get a vote
right if you're gonna call the police
good for you i'm proud of you i know
there's a hard phone call good for you
the second thing is is i think there may
be some merit to what your husband's
saying
um a key component of healing from grief
over time
is relationships with other people
especially relationships where you can
show up and have your good days and have
your really really dark
days and you know you're still loved and
you know that someone
is gonna expect you to be there
if someone's gonna expect you to wake up
someone's gonna um
show up when you can't get out of bed
right that's part of the healing process
and yes there is something about
isolation
here's the thing i don't really care
the why here okay the reality of this
situation is some people don't come back
from trauma like this
and i say don't come back some people
cannot
say goodbye to their mom when they die
some people cannot let go
of that feeling because if they let go
of the feeling then mom's finally gone
dad's finally out of here and
um it's a really tall ask for some folks
and so at the end of the day
four years later is it wrong that she
still thinks to mom and gets her heart
broken and cries
no absolutely not everybody does that
differently right
but if she is putting her burden on you
right then at some point you got to let
her know i love you more than life
itself i'm your sister i'll always be
there for you you can call me at any
time
i'm not going to talk about this anymore
yeah and that's just about you
establishing your boundaries and so what
i would love for you and your husband to
do is to
come up with hey what are husband what's
your husband's name
his name is randy hey randy when i talk
to sister
and i just hang up the phone and i'm
devastated or i'm all spun up or i just
come to you and i'm like hey i need a
couple of tall boys to make my day
better right
whatever whatever you happen to be ask
him
what are the things that she's told me
or you may know what are the things that
really spin you up and that's what you
have a direct conversation with her and
say hey
you grieve how you need to grieve i love
you
we're not talking about i'm not talking
about this with you anymore you talk
about it with a counselor with a pastor
with a therapist
with your friends i am not going to
continue to entertain xyz
yeah right and that's not you loving her
any less in fact
often when people are spiraling and
they're hurting having boundaries
becomes a great great gift and
if she does haul off and hurt herself
that's not your fault
yeah you know what i mean yeah
are you the oldest i am i'm the oldest
out of all of us
and so let me give you another how how
much older are you
than her how far are you i am three
years older than her
okay um sometimes there's this
it's a nerdy psych word called
transference in some ways you might
become mom for her now
and she needs your approval she needs
you to listen she needs to
whine and complain to you the same way
you used to do to your mother and more
importantly
if she has transferred mom to you
there's a part of her brain that says at
any moment you're gonna go next
and so every conversation becomes about
how can i
grab on to you how can i hold tightly
onto you
almost to the point that it strangles
you right or that you're like a little
kid gets around your legs and you can't
walk
it kind of feels like that right yeah
and so that's just you just like any
good older sister any
sibling any friend any mom any dad you
got to develop your boundaries
and then she's going to have the healing
work if she wants to do it
i do think a in this situation
i've seen it over and over uh writing
her a letter that she can hold in her
hand you've heard me say that a million
times
writing her a letter she can hold in her
hand and read and let her know i love
you
and i think it's time for all of us to
let mom go
and then if she calls you back and says
you don't understand it's not this and
that then you've done what you can do
there and then you're gonna draw these
boundaries i'm not gonna talk about this
anymore
yeah is that something you can do
oh yeah i can do that awesome and if
she's willing to
have her call the show i'm i'd love to
talk to her too
oh she loves you guys so i'll probably
convince her
yeah have her have her call and she can
say i'm the sister my older sister's the
worst
rebecca and florida's terrible right she
wouldn't do that but
um yeah at the end of the day how she
grieves is how she grieves
there is a point i always am really
hesitant to say someone should be over
something by now
because that means something it means
something different to so many people
what does over it mean that you're not
crying man you can
be dead on the inside or not crying you
can be completely out of tears
or you can cry every day and be totally
functional you just miss somebody
and some people cry when they miss
people and some people laugh when they
miss people and some people are just
annoying to be around they miss people
it's different for everybody so i'm
never going to say
you got to be over it by now we got to
get up and get going like you got to be
i'm not going to say that but
there is a moment when you have to
whether it's a process whether it's a um
funeral a second funeral hey hey i wanna
get all the brothers and sisters back
like we've had four years to think
through this i want us to all like we're
gonna we're gonna let mom go
like we've been all struggling with this
dealing with this in our own little ways
we're gonna let mom go whatever that
looks like for you
having some sort of moment and then you
gotta be around people who are going to
witness your grief and then help you
move on
help not move on but help you come to
terms with your new life
right so yeah reach out to her tell her
you love her
write her a letter and then draw some
boundaries we're not going to talk about
mom anymore
or we're going to talk about mom in this
way not in that way i'm not going to
talk about your i've
told you this to um we'd help you with
recovery i told you we'd help you with
mental health challenges i told you we'd
do those things you're choosing not to
and that's okay
but i'm not going to be a part of it
anymore right thank you so much for that
callback i know that's hard and i know
it's messy
and i know everybody does grief
differently um at this point you've got
to make sure you and your husband are
well
right you and your husband your kid so
thank you so much for that call